KROVER.
29 SHOTS ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON.
THE PENGUINS HAVE TROUBLE.
JAKE GUENTZEL MAKES IT 1-0,
PENGUINS.
GIVE THEIR TEAM A BREAK.
IT'S A VETERAN TYPE MOVE.
A LITTLE GAMESMANSHIP IF YOU
KRIS LETANG OPENS UP.
CROS BOB, WE SAID
THAT IF
>> Steve: COULD SAVE BY CASEY
DeSMITH.
NINE STOPS . HE
BED HERE. T FE
HE'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL,
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
OPPORTUNURGH.
>> Bob: BOSTON HAS BE IT WAS O
BACKSIDE.
THE PLAY WAS.CASEY
DeSMITH'S SHOULDER.
LOOSE PUCK, RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE ZONE.
THE TAG FINDS THE PUCK.
AND BIG MINUTES TOO, BOB. COMIN
>> Bob: NOW THE BRUINS COME AD
JUGGLED BY CASEY
UP THE WALL.  JOB FOR THE
FOR THE NET.
STOPPED BY JEREMY SWAYMAN. JAKE
THIS PATH OFF-THE-WALL.
JUST A TREMENDOUS PLAY  BY
ETHER CENTER.
DIRECTED BY MATT GRZLCYK.
OVER TO COYL
JEREMY SWAYMAN HAD HIS SHOULDER
AGAINST THAT BAR.
PRETTY GOOD SHOT THERE. THE
DESPERATION GOING HERE.
>> Bob: HERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
RICKARD D BEAUTIFUL FEED AFTER
CURL AND DRAG